prosecutors didn't say whether morse
used his toy to help plan
the capital insurrection the guy didn't
even build the lego set
it was just in the box it's the perfect
cover cover
cover for what i can't break them take
them to the melding chamber what at the
fbi
doing a lot to try to throw these people
in prison who trespassed at the capitol
meanwhile law enforcement is letting a
huge portion of the blm riders
completely off the hook
but the guys who entered the capital big
problem so
the fbi seized piece of evidence from
pennsylvania man who was indicted last
month for his role in the insurrection
the piece of evidence was a logo logo a
lego replica
of the capital big government building
and
lego came out with a lego version of the
capital the daily beast reported
robert morse 27 years old is accused of
leading fellow rioters
in what prosecutors say was one of the
most intense and prolonged clashes with
officers
on january 6. don't forget by the way
they completely lied to us about
officers being killed in the riot just
didn't happen
even the new york times later had to
admit that it didn't happen
they're still insinuating it but they
can't state it outright because it's a
lie
this is according to the daily beast
prosecutors didn't say whether morse
used his toy to help plan
the capital insurrection but
uh obviously they had to take it as
evidence now however
turns out that the guy didn't even build
the lego set
so not only did he not did he not use
the lego toy
of the capital as a way to plan all of
this is we're going to enter here
through this block we're going to make a
turn at this point
no he didn't even open it up it was just
in the box
he didn't even build it this now
quote in original detention memoranda
the undersigned stated that law
enforcement found a fully constructed
u.s capital lego set that statement
appears to be inaccurate the lego set
was in a box and not fully constructed
at the time of the search
this according to the new filing
this is to me the worrisome thing this
is why
i think uh even some radical right
winger being kicked off of twitter
is a is a worrisome move
the most radical fringy ostracized
low influence right wing
is being treated as the terrorist threat
to the country
and the things that they are doing are
no worse
and often not even close to as bad as
what the mainstream left is doing i
guess the perfect example of this is the
difference
between the capital riot which we're
told is the worst event that ever
happens worse than pearl harbor it's
worse than 911
versus the blm riots which actually
killed many
many people and destroyed countless
homes and stores and burned down
multiple cities for months and months at
a time
and that we're told as a mostly peaceful
protest
some radical right-wing guy who's been
ostracized who has a very small
following relatively
says odious and offensive things
on race and sex and whatever we are told
this is the greatest threat we need to
kick him out of the society
mark lamont hill says things that are
just as odious if not more odious
he has a program he hasn't got a twitter
feed
ibram kennedy is given awards
undeservedly so
that is the fear here there is no
standard this is not it's not even
it's not even that it's hypocrite
there's a meme going around
it's not even that it's hypocrisy it's a
hierarchy
the leftist agenda prioritized
any sort of conservative agenda
ostracized delegitimized
and censored hold up i'm glad you like
that clip you can get the whole episode
on this youtube channel it's called
culture wars the phantom menace
you can also get it on apple podcast
stitch your google play spotify myspace
xanga live journal all over the place
you can also
get my book speechless controlling words
controlling minds thank you for sending
this book to the top of the best seller
lists
even if the lib bestseller lists don't
want to acknowledge it we'll see you
next time